jusqu'ici la recherche en foresterie
s'est concentrée surtout sur les arbres
mais l'écosystème des forêts est
immensément riche
on commence donc à se pencher sur de
tout petits hôtes des insectes qui joue
un rôle méconnu dans ces vastes milieu
[Musique]
ses hommes vont faire une récolte plutôt
original ils viennent tôt en saison
parce qu'ils doivent arriver avant le
réveil des insectes
voici ce qu'ils viennent chercher des
bûches de bois
il s'intéresse enfin à la vi contenues
dans ce bois mort beaucoup d'espèces qui
dépendent du bois mans les organisent
des composants des insectes les
bactéries les champignons mais aussi
tous les organismes qui vont s'alimenter
sur ces organismes les oiseaux
insectivores instituée donc c'est
vraiment une partie importante de la
chaîne alimentaire en forêt
ce sont des bûches d'épinettes noires
elles ont été récoltés sur place et mise
par terre il ya plus d'un an
nous sommes dans l'arrière pays de
montmagny l'un des douze cette
expérimentation de mathieu bouchard il a
fait mettre des bus comme celle là à
plusieurs endroits au québec de la
limite nord des arbres jusqu'au sud de
montréal parce qu'il veut voir dans
quelle mesure le climat influence la vie
dans le bois mort à ce que les fenêtres
noir qui est présente au sud territoires
au nord de ce territoire va être
colonisée par les mêmes espèces est ce
qu'elles boivent à se dégrader la même
vitesse aux différents endroits
probablement pauvres les recherches de
mathieu bouchard sont exploratoire mais
à terme elle pourrait influencer la
façon dont on gère les forêts jusqu'ici
l'industrie forestière ne s'est pas
vraiment intéressé à la vie dans le bois
mort on essaie de récolter pour le
transformer donc il faut rester rick est
très efficace mais il faut restaurer qui
va ciment qui vont mener à la
disparition ce bois en forêt or le
ministère veut orienter la coupe de bois
de façon à diminuer l'écart entre les
forêts récoltés et les forêts naturelles
autrement dit préserver le plus possible
la biodiversité originel c'est ce que
les spécialistes appellent de
l'aménagement écosystémique
comme il ya toujours des arbres morts en
forêt il faudrait théoriquement en
laisser sur place après les coupes pour
se rapprocher des conditions naturelles
d'eau ministère fait déjà des
recommandations à cet effet mais sans se
baser sur des données précises
combien d'arbres morts laissés sur place
et lesquelles
aussi pas mal répartis à l'échelle du
paysage donc est ce qu un peuplement
avec beaucoup de bois mort dans un grand
paysage plusieurs dizaines ou centaines
de kilomètres carrés ou yoko de bois
mort est-ce que c'est suffisant ou sanaa
reprend plusieurs comment les organismes
dans l'espace ce qu'on fait des
corridors avec des peuplements ou en
gagnent certaine quantité de bois mort
pour leur permettre de se déplacer de se
disperser même la façon de couper la
forêt pour être un jour être influencé
par ses recherches il faut penser à
l'avenir dans quel type de coupes
pourraient nous permettre de laisser des
arbres qui vont mourir plus tard dans
dix quinze vingt ans puis qui vont
continuer à assurer une certaine
quantité débiteur pour les espèces qui
dépendent de ce type des tribunaux
parmi tous les organismes qui vivent
dans le bois mort ce sont surtout les
insectes qui intéresse mathieu bouchard
ce sont de bons indicateurs de la
biodiversité
mais on les connaît mal beaucoup de
chercheurs se sont penchés sur les
insectes qui suivent les feux de forêt
comme le longicorne noir parce qu'ils
ont une importance économique directe
ils font perdre de la valeur au bois
récoltés
mais ceux qui vivent dans les arbres
morts des forêts scène n'ont pas encore
été étudiés sur l'ensemble du québec
ceux là ont plutôt une importance
écologique pour la biodiversité
il est possible par exemple que
certaines espèces soit actuellement en
déclin par manque de bois mort on n'en
sait rien on a de plus en plus de
pression en milieu forestier pour
essayer de conserver toutes ces espèces
le projet ce vendéen protéger mais aussi
dans les forêts qui sont aménagés 1 2 ou
3 c bat mathieu bouchard et samuel
lauzon ne récolteront pas tout les
bûches aujourd'hui ils reviendront
l'année prochaine et les années
suivantes
histoire de voir comment la vie aura
évolué dans le bois qui se décompose car
les espèces changent avec le temps les
trous creusés par les premiers arrivés
deviennent des portes d'entrée pour
d'autres êtres vivants comme les
champignons eux mêmes mangés par de
nouveaux insectes qu'on dit fonds givors
un des centaines voire des milliers
d'espèces d'insectes au québec seulement
principalement sur des champions ces
recherches apporteront aussi de
nouvelles données sur le cycle du
carbone dans les forêts ya beaucoup de
carbone qui est convenu dans le bois
mort donc y restent pendant un certain
temps le temps que se compose de mieux
quantifier foresti
les bûches sont entreposés dans ce
garage le temps qu émerge tous les
insectes qu'elles contiennent
on place chacune dans un contenant bien
fermé mais aéré avec au-dessous impôts
d'alcool les insectes qui sortent de la
bûche finissent par y tomber dans ce pot
par exemple il y à la récolte d'un mois
provoqué tout de suite un espace de
quatre semaines énormément d'essais qui
ont émergé régulièrement le contenu des
pots et transférés dans un liquide de
conservation normalement ce qu'on trouve
au début comme ce donc après à peu près
un an depuis que l'air vraiment cdc les
ac qui colonise l'arbre immédiatement
après la mort dont mais plus on atteint
souvent un petit peu plus longtemps mais
lui il va voir davantage d'insectes qui
vont au kivu ont colonisé plus le bois
plus décomposer les champignons et stud
c'est au laboratoire que commence le
travail le plus fastidieux
l'identification le monde des insectes
est si complexe que les techniciens du
ministère ne sont pas toujours capables
d'identifier les espèces
il faut parfois faire appel à des
spécialistes c'est vraiment comme un
petit écosystème l'intérieur d'une bûche
pour plusieurs dizaines voire même plus
qu'une centaine d'espèces qui vont
interagir comme ces insectes seront
conservés les données recueillies ici
pourront servir à étudier par exemple
l'effet des changements climatiques sur
les populations d'insectes qui vivent
dans le bois mort ça nous donne un point
de départ un honnête situation espèce de
baseline peut-être dans dix vingt trente
quarante ans que d'autres chercheurs qui
vont arriver et puis le haut ces données
le web disponible même si les insectes
sont concernés identifié l'espèce tout
le temps
même si mathieu bouchard et son équipe
aboutissent à des résultats probants
les applications sont loin d'être
évidente la forêt est un lieu de
compromis
comment répondre aux besoins des
industries des autochtones des
villégiateurs tout en respectant les
préoccupations sociales
donc ces données le vont nous aider à
réfléchir parce qu'on est à l'état de
beaucoup de réfléchir comment ajuster
nos stratégies d'aménagement pour
réussir à atteindre nos objectifs de
conservation biodiversité dans un
contexte et la foresterie mousse des
changements climatiques
[Musique]